je voulais vivre un peu comme un ermite
parce que je trouve que dans les villes
tout va trop vite et je voulais prendre
justement du temps pour moi
[Musique]
début mai il neige toujours températures
négatives
c'est quoi il fait en 5 degrés dehors
l'intérieur l'eau gèle pas encore mais
c'est quoi
deux ou trois degrés quoi en fait il
faisait froid constamment j'ai passé
deux mois des températures qui dépassait
pas 6 degrés
je passais mes journées dans un sac de
couchage c'était le seul endroit où
j'avais plus ou moins fous
[Musique]
on va commencer par le toit évidemment
c'était là de la vieille tall qui était
pas étanche qui était pas isolant de
rien du tout donc là ce que j'ai fait
j'ai quand même gardé la toile parce que
ça porte ses impôts dgi des rigidités et
gimmi un géotextile par dessus puis une
bâche pdm une grosse bâche noire
continue pour les mares ensuite
géotextile encore du compost et du gazon
et on rentre pas la prendre comme prévu
aussi leur poser ici avec du poids que
j'ai coupé
je fais tout à la hache l assise au
ciseau à bois tout à la main j'ai aussi
d'éclairage électricité par un panneau
solaire que m'a fabriqué mon père donc
j'essaie de faire le plus naturellement
possible par exemple à les enduits c'est
aussi du sable de l'argile que j'ai
creusé pour ensuite mélangée avec de la
chaux donc j'essaye d'avoir un maximum
de matériaux que j'ai pu trouver
vraiment sur place et le reste ce sont
quelques petites choses complémentaires
[Musique]
avant d'ajouter des petits zen réglisse
menthe
mais depuis j'ai trouvé ici de la
réglisse et de l'amant et c'est bien
meilleur symbole et tête de
c'est un des meilleurs comestibles on
reconnaît bien les volets parce qu'ils
ont tous des tubes sous le chapeau kono
podium majus commode et sa crue c'est un
goût de noisette pour l'alimentation au
début j'avais la nourriture parce que
ici et c'était en sortie de fin d'hiver
il y avait vraiment rien à manger rien
car rien à cultiver mais ensuite quand
l'été est arrivé là je vais faire des
cueillette de plantes sauvages que je
connaissais dans la montagne
j'ai fait aussi pousser un potager donc
j'avais les légumes frais et petits pois
des fèves des betteraves des choux les
épluchures de légumes
je donne aux poules qui sont dans le
poulailler ici l'époux me donne des
oeufs et aussi de la fiente que je peux
mettre dans un temps dans le poulailler
d'un système qu'ils marchent de pair
les cds redire ici mon maximum mon
appart carbone après il y aura toujours
un peu d'impact carbone qui sera caché
darcis douala par exemple pour j'utilise
des casseroles en métal ya aussi un coup
je mon éclairage led aussi il ya un coup
j'ai considéré que ces éléments sont
tellement petits et faibles et qui vont
durer pendant très longtemps que
l'impact est très minimisée et en vivent
ici je m'aperçois que les ressources
sont vraiment limités donc par exemple
pour les vergers de quantités limitées
d'électricité pour aller chercher de
l'eau il au jeune âge pendant cinq
minutes pour trouver de l'eau à une
source pour moi c'est devenu quelque
chose de précieux la nourriture ces
précieux l'eau c'est précieux
je fais un maximum d'économies je ne
vais pas m'amuser à gaspiller des litres
et des litres pour faire la vaisselle je
fais vraiment le minimum pour prendre
une douche par exemple j'utilise à peine
2 litres d'eau
[Musique]